okay so we have this uh concept and IO
that and just use my phrase so the
spiral rotating
cross sometimes they just say rotating
cross but uh spiral rotating is is the
best way of understanding spiral
rotation um of course this will have
some physical properties but it is not
entirely a physical statement about
reality okay um this is a metaphysical
concept um and you should know that from
the simple fact that what you're
rotating is uh Yin and yangong and Yin
and yangong does not exist in physical
reality Yin and yangong has uh physical
manifestations but the yin and yang
itself does not exist in reality it is a
metaphysical concept
okay um so we have to keep that in mind
and they're just representatives of Yin
and Y in a simple form you you have this
okay and as I've mentioned before this
pattern or some variation of this
pattern that there's one side of reality
or the cosmos and another side of the
cosmos is just Universal along the Silk
Road culture Okay so uh for example I've
given you that you you have what has
become the um I'm
sorry the Star of David only
erace which is a symbol today of uh
Judaism but uh it's a yinong symbol
okay um another one you have is your is
your SW your swastika symbols oh
these are all yinong symbols okay and
these are all Hitler took uh them from
uh India and they're yinyang symbols
okay or more
broadly they're part of the Triune
cosmology that was developed through the
Silk Road and Triune cosmology again is
there's two things that are in a
dichotomous relationship
um that are a manifestation of a third
thing that is beyond description Beyond
materiality uh so on the west side of
the Silk Road you would have for example
uh God the god concept uh on the east
side of the Silk Road you would have
heaven or you would have Dow um even a
god concept as well but beyond
description
okay and sometimes times that
metaphysics is
described um sequentially so the Dow
existed first and then yin and yang came
from the doubt for example but the
understanding is more like a a kind of
pulsating so the da manifest the yin and
yangong the yin and yangong can be uh
Dem manifested and you return to the
doubt and it just this process just
keeps going going on and on this is the
nature of the universe
okay in our Kon
waza and what you're trying to do in
Kona as a purification
ritual is that process of undoing Yin
and yangong returning to the Dow State
and then REM manifesting Yin and yangong
so in the study of Religion this these
rituals are have been called the rituals
of eternal return so you kind of uh
uncreate and create uncreate and create
uncreate and
create and why this is a type of
purification ritual is there's nothing
more pure than the pre yinong State the
doubt because there's always some
corruption and degeneration that
immediately happens after the Dual the
universe is split up into dichotomy so
the purest state is the god State the
Dow State the heaven State hence for
Sensei these are misogi which is
purification rituals
okay uh and the way that you you undo
this is in essence you destabilize them
by spiral rotating them that in their
purest ideal State they want to act in
this dichotomous relationship so they're
kind of two things one's horizontal
one's vertical and the way to
destabilize the dichotomy here is you're
going to spiral rotate and as you spiral
rotate uh it's hard for them to remain
in their pure dichotomous State and
eventually uh they break apart okay and
you return to a dow state or a zero
state or however you want to describe
that okay
so when we look at keto
keaza and we're going to look from above
and I'm I only have a two-dimensional
capacity here so any of you uh patrons
you have any access to 3D modeling on a
computer yeah go for it okay uh your
iido geometry your iido
Kona tactical geometry is is going to be
taking this shape you you and uh UK take
on this shape you you have this kind of
spiral
okay and uh on that spiral so we're
going to just look
at will you throw that in
the we'll just take a section of that
line
okay on this shape here here's that line
aside from both UK and N doing this
we're now going to take a section of
that line and we're only going to look
at uh UK's body on that line okay so
here's that section on the line and
we're going to look at UK's body on that
line we'll represent his his
spine uh with another line and here we
see that we have that cross position
so here's UK's head and here's UK's feet
okay and here is UK's center of
gravity and we do want to understand it
that way at this level at this point it
it is the physical center of gravity
don't get all crazy with is it the Hara
is it the tonden don't it it does not
make sense to talk about the lower
tonden and as if the actual physical
center of gravity is not contained
therein when we're talking about
throwing architectures it is so we're
talking about the physical center of
gravity
okay UK's
posture is as you can see a microcosmic
representation of the dichotomous
manifestation of the Dow meaning I have
uh a center but the center only exists
because the two ends exist okay and that
makes up ukas
posture and what we're going to do along
the
technique is start to tilt ukas posture
so this is that line This is that line
in a moment in time when UK's
posture is in perfect Triune alignment
so the head is in a relationship with
the
feet and over the feet on the other side
of the center of gravity but at
different points this
line starts to look like this this
relationship okay and you were just
turning
it over
as you're going
okay so that that is why it's not just a
spiral it's on the spiral UK is rotating
you
see um that's why I use spiral rotation
okay at a certain
point on this now we go back onto this
spiral and you can't imagine that uh UK
is UK's lever is starting to change
relationship with this thing as it's
going around
okay at a certain point because of
especially because of the centrifugal
and centripetal forces so you have Force
going out and you have Force going in
because we're guiding them on the
spiral at a certain point
this structure of UK what I mean by is
the relationship between the head and
the feet being a center becomes
radically or radically
destabilized okay and they start to go
in different directions this one goes
there this one goes there this one goes
there for example because the the makeup
of this thing
disassembles in this ritual you
see and
uh this means UK's head is going in one
vector UK's Center is going in a to
entirely different vector and UK's feet
is going in an entirely different Vector
altoe okay and this is when finally a
actual human body is being
thrown as opposed to a choreographed UK
so a choreographed UK never loses this
relationship but anytime UK has this
relationship UK is in control UK has
form we want to undo it we want to
return it back to its pre-form state
okay and this is where you actually have
a full-on deconstruction of hookus
posture they're being physically thrown
uh some of you have noted how our
UK uh can't take the regular ukami some
of you are working uh or don't take the
regular ukami some of you are working
with your
UK without training them in this kind of
ukemi I'm about to show you and you
realize they can't do the fall um and
they know they can't do the fall so they
try to pull out of the technique all
kinds of things like that happen okay
uh in short the modern UK is just
not familiar with a dismantling of this
Yin Yong makeup between the head the
center and the feet okay but we want to
we want to understand that so uh that's
what we're going to do today this is how
everyone should be
rolling and uh we'll just work at the
forward roll if again we have a a a
member board with a ranking and you
could plot for who rolls this
way and who does not roll This Way those
who roll this way are at the higher uh
Rank and those who do not roll this way
are at the lower rank that is um the way
it works out because rank here is
dependent upon who can take who can me
and who cannot take a kemy because you
can only
receive what you can receive so
transmission is entirely dependent upon
your ability to receive and so skill is
dependent upon transmission hence rank
as we understand it here okay so this
gives us opportunity for our people to
go back over on how to roll and this
gives you opportunity a very important
one that if you're going to take our
throwing
architectures uh which will make more
sense to you as you understand our Force
engine mechanics you have to retrain
your people on how to roll because
they're currently not rolling in a way
that is safe for what we are doing and
more
importantly this is how UK experiences
the purification ritual uh that comes
from this ritual of eternal return where
you have Yin and y you undo yin and
yangong and then you end up back with
yin and yangong okay all
right okay here we have his uh we'll
just call it Jong in this case and then
we have the center and then we have the
yin his feet and this gives an order
this is a order a concentric order of
the whole manifestation of the universe
and what we want to do is undo this
order okay and he's going to experience
that through his body mind he he's going
to feel the order of his body and then
of his body mind and then he's going to
feel the the the disorder of it okay so
he experiences this ritual of eternal
return from that point of view okay um
and this is why true KY as I just
defined it is terrifying because he has
to undo himself uh it's a kind of little
death there the kind of death that
happens for UK every single time they're
thrown uh This Way um and that's the
ritual you see it's a ritual of freedom
from self there a kind of death that
happens okay and at the physical level
it happens because this order is going
to reach that destabilization state
where these things these three things go
in different directions okay um so
when what we're going to end up doing
I'll kind of demonstrate this is he we
would be on that spiral shape any
portion of it okay and we're just
working with the forward Emi that the
head is moving uh
along and with the inward D the inward
Force the um cental Force okay on that
spiral
shape the leg is moving
outwardly this way
okay so there is this kind of spin here
that's happening on his
body and if we just look at his
body the way it is eventually that
rotation is going to take his line of
gravity outside the Bas of support of
that
foot but what the technique does also
differently is it's going to take the
line of gravity and cut it usually we
have this angle I'm sorry the center
gravity usually this angle or this angle
okay uh is what you end up doing so his
Center gravity is going to go that way
on a line his foot is on a
curve going that way and his head is on
a curve going this way okay so
uh you're just going to push his foot on
the curve when I say go
go that's what we're doing okay you
increase the momentum you increase the
inertia and it's impossible for someone
to stand okay that's what we're doing
there um what we have to do differently
in the
end is is he will be dismantled in his
posture but he will refine his posture
and imp particular he's going to find it
on this arm for the forward roll but
different from the normal roll is this
hand touches the the mat on the other
side of the circle of the forward roll
okay so I'll demonstrate that so uh if
you have a forward roll
a lot of people will touch the mat on
the positive side of the forward roll
and it looks something like
this what we have to do is touch the mat
on the negative side of the forward
R I'm on the other side of the circle
that is when I start to restructure the
relationship between my head my center
and my feet okay so if you watch my UK
that I'm legitimately
throwing they kind of have to let these
things pull
apart and they'll find that arm on the
negative side of the circle take it back
into that unyong relationship through
the center so we have to roll a certain
way to be able to find the arm on the
negative side of the circle okay
so here's drill
one in drill one we're going to organize
the body and we start out with this
right angle with our
legs your lead leg is pointed exactly
straight this is incorrect this kind of
tilt that you have there
straight this leg no 90 you want these
strict um XY AIS going okay and on drill
one I start to get used to building the
relationship between the head the center
and the feet okay my hand comes down
usually your heel Palm straight
underneath your shoulder or near
thereabouts I don't know where you have
to move to show that
camera and your
knee is in alignment with your heel Palm
but is what's important is that your
this is a natural position for your hand
because the only thing this hand is
doing is creating a kind of training
balance like training wheels so we don't
want it out here we don't want it out
here we don't want it out here it's just
so you can have some sort of guide rail
stair rail where you can now balance on
this leg okay and here you start to
develop that relationship between your
head and feet which means your every
time your foot moves your head goes down
head moves foot goes down so foot up
head down head up foot down what you
don't want is this this is incorrect
this this is has no Center to it because
the extremities are acting independently
so drill one just hang out
here back
down okay we'll try drill one some uh
common mistakes at this point already is
to use the support hand as if it's going
to be there in the technique it will not
be there in the technique okay um
relatedly is a will for control that's
why they want to use that hand okay
they're not going to find that control
and relatedly to this will for control
is that they're going to try to touch
the ground on the positive side of the
circle but they they won't be there at
that point on the positive side of the
circle which is the throwing part of the
circle there are
disassembled this is why you my lesser
skilled ukas can't take this is they're
trying to look for the contact with the
mat on the positive side of the circle
which means they're trying to not be
disassembled okay why because of the
fear attachment that comes to the the
self being dis disassembled okay so
sometimes that's going to make um
someone put this hand over here if they
want a wider base so they can balance
more and this is all part of that I want
control
here
um you don't you you you're not trying
to touch anything in fact okay just just
that you're trying to work on this
relationship trying to balance here okay
so careful that you're trying to widen
your base because that's the positive
side of the circle relatedly let's say
you do put your hand here but you put
this shoulder down so you're actually
using it the shoulders down when I'm
doing it you can see that shoulder goes
up so I'm not here like this the
shoulder is up I'm more sideways as I'm
doing this more sideways so you can be
light light and your balance is more on
your leg and your foot but really in
your Center working very much like
warrior pose in yoga as opposed to
getting ready to do my forward roll
shoulder down widen my face touch the
mat on the positive side of circle okay
so get their shoulders up try
it drill two is I'm going to lower that
shoulder all the way down all the way
down it is fine if you start to fall
okay you you do want to fall eventually
so uh and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to lift the foot up until that
shoulder I'm lifting the foot up I'm not
lowering the shoulder and breaking the
connection with my foot I lift the foot
up lift the foot up then the foot goes
down and I come back up okay so again
you're here don't start to lower the
shoulder you get this Arc right here or
this angle here no lift the foot up lift
the foot up lift the foot up lift the
foot up shoulders down okay to this
leave your hand flat on the mat
don't turn this hand like this uh
especially Palm up cuz this is where
we're going to hit the hit the mat so
some Palm off the mat is fine no
no no okay so I'm here like
this hey
right okay some details that you want to
be able to see on this drill is of
course no head on the mat uh you don't
want to have your head on the mat uh but
two is you're going to have to emphasize
the opening of that of that rear
shoulder um and not keep it down and as
a result you're going to end up looking
around that balance a guide rail arm so
my head doesn't doesn't look through
here I'm going to end up looking around
that arm so I'm looking around that
arm looking around the
arm okay because my feet and my head and
my Center are going different directions
um what we are accomplishing already at
this point is that my head my my head
shoulder area is no longer in the same
plane as my hips and that is very
important okay so as I'm doing drill two
and if I do a normal fedorite forward
roll when I'm here like this do this
kind of stuff there's the positive uh
aspect of the circle where I'm putting
weight and I have weight here uh my hips
are following my shoulders even if I
have a slight diagonal they're basically
in the same plane they're going to go
over the top okay that's not possible in
our throwing
architecture so drill
three as I start to move around my head
comes around you can see that my
shoulders aren't in the same plane as my
hips they're starting to go around this
way and you should already see that in
drill two I'm going this
way I'm not going this way drill three
once I I'm going to complete drill uh
two and then I'm going to push with the
ball of my front foot I push on the ball
of the front foot way drill
two push
over drill
two push over you're going to start to
notice
something here I am on that line
my hips will not go that way or even
stay on this line they going to go that
[Music]
way knee on the line foot on the line my
hips will go that way not here not here
my shoulders will go this way my hips go
that
way okay let's try that Dr three
okay so your hips are on the line go
back to the other side
switch same side scoot
back your
hips put your knee on that line
please your hips are going to go to far
to the right of the line your shoulders
are going to come far to the left of the
line what we're trying to do is get them
out of the same plane right okay so
point to where your hips are going to go
more there you go okay where your
shoulders going to go okay lower to do
drill
two lower and now push and get
go better
again there you go
all right here's where this right angle
comes is more important is when we're
upside
down I don't want my knees to come
towards each
other so as I'm rolling and I my hips
are going this way my shoulders are
going this way I don't want my knees to
come together because now I'm sideways
okay and you kind of get up all weird
[Music]
so keep your knees
open and
apart and I'll give you a
metric for for to learn this part of
don't turn sideways that's what we're
learning okay CU eventually this will
have to go away just like this guard
gril will have to go away too
okay is the bottom of my foot
of my forward leg should be as if I
stepping flat on the ceiling if your
knees come together your foot is over
that way which eventually we want our
foot that way but not right now okay so
as I
[Music]
roll my foot my left
foot is going to
stay towards the ceiling where I could
plant it flat on the mat continue
forward and you have the same L shape
shouldn't be here at this point okay so
in this
drill drill
four we look for that on the ceiling of
the front foot and then we complete
it being ready to do it again okay try
it uh there's a lot of L problems right
now and this is the the dangerous part
or the the the the inefficient part of
teaching
this um one for example is that we have
that guard rail but that this and you're
going to put weight on it that's a false
problem because you're not going to have
that arm in the throat um the other
problem
is this uh this closing of the knees
like kind of thing that's a false
problem to you won't be able to close
your knees that will only affect how
well you are at coming back together at
the end okay uh so basically you crash
it's a false
problem uh also your your
uh the uh the positive side of the
circle your your beginner is going to
want to do that no matter how much you
tell them they are balancing with the
two hands as opposed to with the head
Center foot relationship okay and so
they kind of put pressure on that arm or
they uh put pressure on the shoulder
they use the shoulder uh as the positive
side of the circle to replace the arm
but that is also a false problem okay
you have to make sure that you're doing
drill two drill two is lower the
shoulder lower the shoulder okay um it
might seem like to some people that well
I'd rather put weight on the arm so I
could roll over that and not the
shoulder and this is what I mean by it's
a false problem you're not going to have
your shoulder your shoulder is going to
be underneath when we throw you which is
why you can only touch the mat on the
negative side of the circle you have no
chance of crashing on your shoulder when
we throw you okay it's just a matter of
how you will land is the diff is the
question if you're going through the air
and it's not on your shoulder okay
usually you end up flat on your back and
you're you get Whiplash and your head
hits the M okay um so and make sure that
you're going to lower that shoulder and
not crash on that shoulder that's
positive side of the circle
mentality what we really want out of
this is what I said the shoulders and
the hips are an entirely different ples
cuz they are going to be in different
planes they're going to disorganize me
okay and a Telltale sign that you're
doing it is your head is looking around
your arm your shoulder on the guard rail
is up and your back is straight if your
shoulders and hips are in the same plane
you got to kind of Tuck to pass the
bottom Apex because you made a bottom
Apex so we want to really emphasize this
back straight here that I have in drill
one and drill two so as I come around
you'll be able to keep your back
straight as that leg is swinging around
and taking your hips that way and make
sure you're not tucking your back is
straight As You
Go Okay so let's try it make sure your
back's straight
go Okay so because my main goal is to
keep the hips and the shoulders in
different planes different vertical
planes I don't want my hips ever moving
towards the plane my shoulders is are in
which means I don't want my knees moving
towards my face okay so pay attention
I'll just going to let you go you do
[Music]
you better
they went towards your
face and as a as a result you can see
that her hips stay on that line even
though at the end you kind of move to
your left okay let let yourself let your
hips go way to the to your left okay
don't let your knees come towards your
face better one
[Music]
more okay and and you're really using
that front shoulder as a balancing thing
you got to you you you go over it you
push over it you fall over it okay all
right continue There we go this is
looking
good well I'll just film you going the
other way we'll get your hips going the
other way okay you can go
[Music]
again look at his shoulder look at his
hips look at his back straight all these
things look how the knees don't come
towards the
face he looks around the arm
okay
e e
in drill five what we're going to do is
take away any any uh support that
someone might have been having here okay
on the positive side of the circle any
positive side of the circle mentality
we're going to take it away by going
onehanded okay now people who uh were
doing it correctly will actually find
this easier to do because there's no uh
impetus to have the rear shoulder down
because you don't have to touch the mat
okay you get to actually put it up more
and the more the rear shoulder is up the
easier it is to move the shoulders and
the head out of the same vertical plane
with the hips which is what we want
because that's what's going to happen to
us okay um it's just an easier drill for
them for the person that was still with
the positive side of the circle
mentality which again is a Will To Power
which is a fear response you're trying
to gain some control which will never be
there for you in the throw uh which will
have you crash and land
improperly uh then you can't take Camy
then the art can't be transmitted to you
and you are where you are okay uh what
they will find is this is even this is
scarier okay because you won't have that
so um it looks something like this
everything's exactly the
same you just rolling it's
lower and you can see that I'm moving
more
North as I go
because my hips keep going to the
outside of each line you should be doing
that anyone who's rolling straight East
West the entire time wasn't doing this
correctly okay all right let's try that
all right here's a drill
5.1 okay because at this point you can
stick in the arm finding and using the
negative side of the circle so he's
going to do drill five but not put that
shoulder down
okay and he'll hit the mat on the
negative side of the circle with his uh
lead arm and it looks something like
this okay try it